hi it's ria today i've been challenged
to take a popular food and make it fancy
as a reminder if you want to check out
our merch go to
shopmakingfancy.com today's challenger
is katie hey rea i am so excited to be
challenging you on this episode of make
it fancy it's been a while i also have
become a recent member of a very cool
adult club costco
i want you to make a costco rotisserie
chicken fancy i know you're going to do
something wild and awesome and it's
probably going to involve booze so
can't wait to see it
costco rotisserie chicken i've never had
this before and also i've never been to
costco oh it's heavy hefty
it smells good it looks great it's nice
brown color how much do you think this
costs
12.99 4.99
the whole chicken do they have their own
farm so there is not a lot of artificial
ingredients this is already fancy
despite of the price i think this is the
fanciest ingredients i've ever
challenged
well seasoned it's tender it's a little
bit dry it's very tasty seasoning is
very simple i want to make something
creative upgrade not a transformation
for this time this is a great challenge
and as always i'm excited to make it
fancy
alright here's what i got carrots
parsley thyme heavy cream oyster
mushroom shiitake mushroom king trumpet
mushroom onions potatoes garlics chives
butter tar onions and pancetta from the
pantry i got flour red wine and
brownie double alcohol alright let's get
started
[Applause]
make it fancy
[Music]
we have whole chicken and i use gloves
so when these come out
you have to grab them so fast because so
many people want them and the boxes are
so hot
so you can
hold it that's kind of gives me anxiety
too not sure if i want to fight that
so i'm going to cut up chicken chicken
hearts join and you put your knife it
kind of separates by itself and you have
to cut through
joints not born is excited and like
sharp knife is important when you are
cutting because if it's dull you cannot
do a knife clean cut especially the skin
the wing you're gonna use it for later
and breast you also kind of see the line
so go
kind of follow that line
here's your breast i think if you know
chicken anatomy it's easier to
breast oh i saw the wishbone i'm going
to use meat and
carcass in two different ways adding
carcass in an instant pot i think this
is
also like instant pop season one onion
cutting quarter three sprigs of thyme
adding three cups of water
to the lid
oh it's always confusing
it's obvious i don't have it at home use
pressure cook mode and cook for 45
minutes if you don't have instant pot at
home you can just use regular pot bring
it
bring it to a boil and cook for 20
minutes i also want to use the leftover
juice save this for later 45 minutes
later so we waited a little bit so the
steam naturally released open this
and strained the chicken stock out the
rotisserie chicken already seasoned so i
think it will be great for later i have
dutch oven and i'm heating medium low
heat cook pancetta i have six ounce i'm
going to render the fat and you want to
do low and slow i
was advised a few people i should get
costco membership because diapers a
great deal
mainly diapers and also one of my
friends told me jazz it's great deal as
well my family is small family i don't
buy a lot of bulk things and if you get
34 bathroom tissue where do you store so
you want to cook pancetta low medium
heat or low heat so you can blend out
those fat if you cook high heat you get
nice caramelized and fat doesn't blender
and also when you're cooking bacon you
want to start with
colder pan or low heat it's the same
reason you want to render those fat out
oh i saw someone recently tagged me
on the instagram this person made candy
corn macaron and fruit loop cream
puffs just do i think this one is easy
enough to make a home so when you make
anything from makey fancy tag me on
instagram my account it's the desktop
panchetta is nice and crisp up transfer
to paper towel lined plate add one diced
onion
and two carrots
and i have mixed mushroom total eight on
seeds i'm just using half and i'm going
to use remaining mushroom for later cook
until softened raise the heat to medium
high heat and saute until all the
ingredients are soft and begin to
caramerize
what is the origin of your instagram
name i like dessert and when i was
looking for dessert snob was taken so i
just put did that smell i don't know
snobby it's not a great word so maybe i
should change it right it looks good so
i'm going to add finely chopped garlic
and cook until fragrant add in two
tablespoons of tomato paste stir in
adding one tablespoon of flour cook one
to two minutes so it doesn't have a like
floury flavor now i'm adding about three
tablespoons of brandy deglaze bottom of
the pan where
flavor is stuck two cups of red wine so
i'm gonna just go in
bring this to a simmer
adding one cup of chicken stock i made
earlier bay leaf in thyme bring this to
simmer and reduce this by half or about
15 to 20 minutes so so it's reduced very
nice smell i wish you guys can smell add
the chicken i cut earlier i feel like
the breast is a little too big so i'm
going to cut it in half put the lid on
top and cook for 20 minutes
so i am heating up frying pan over
medium heat melt one tablespoon of
butter and adding two tablespoons of
olive oil and heat up until butter is
completely melted adding eight ounce
seeds of frozen pearl onion cook until
those are caramelized taro onion is
caramelized and i'm going to add rest of
the mushroom season with salt veggies
are done but we have more things to do
or
plenty of water i'm adding two cup
potatoes bling it to a boil and cook
this potato until tender so when you're
cooking potato you want to make sure to
start with cold water because if you
start cooking with hot water outside
it's cooked but inside it doesn't cook
potato is cooked through and i'm going
to strain water you can just strain in a
sink like this but the sink is fake so
i'm using strainer on the table but this
is not how you do it usually you put
this in a glass bowl set aside until i
use it heating up one cup of cream and
10 tablespoons of butter reserved
chicken fat and juice from the costco
rotisserie chicken 8 cloves of smashed
garlic bring this to simmer the cream is
come to simmer i'm going to strain this
and i'm adding cream mixture little by
little and smashed potato add a little
more
and i'm going to season with salt and
pepper
the chicken fat flavor
definitely comes through the mashed
potatoes tastes good and let's move on
since katie is coming i'm going to play
for her and for myself you want to do
one
white me and one dark meat so chicken
breast here
chicken leg
add
this delicious sauce add rest of the
chicken
in here
at home you can
cooked paul onions and mushroom in the
sauce but i think it's so pretty so i'm
going to just garnish afterwards i also
have pancetta
and i'm going to use these for the big
plate
sprinkle some chives with the mashed
potato
pour
pussary and we are done
[Music]
costco rotisserie chicken cocoa bun
delicious
welcome back katie
hi
are you katie
are you horrified
it's really scary if you want to thank
you i do enjoy it
my husband and everything yes
i heard you recently got the costco
membership i did i was very excited is
it what's that it is absolutely i was
like i don't need this much like toilet
paper but you do like it's just one trip
to you
i have really enjoyed my costco
membership you need to know exactly what
you're going in there for you're going
to come out with like a like a watch
like a patio like chair
so i made a costco rotisserie chicken
coco i don't do anything like this fancy
i just put some on the plate
[Music]
so much flavor i think this is very
rustic crunch dish but it looks fancy it
has brandy and it has to work but i knew
you're gonna need something with booze
double alcohol you definitely made it
fancy thank you is it easy to upgrade
like this or did this take a little bit
of time no this is super easy so like
anyone can make a home we have one more
things to do
what
three two
make it
[Music]
wow